[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
la verdad es que yo tenía un caletre de
esto listo preparado desde hace varias
semanas tenía un guión tenía una cosa
y voy a hablar de esto de esta manera
porque sí porque sí porque sí
pero llegando a este sitio alguien una
chica que no conozco me hizo una
pregunta y esa pregunta alteró
absolutamente todo
y adiós el caletre y todo lo que va a
pasar de aquí en adelante es básicamente
flujo de conciencia y lo que se me
ocurra
que es básicamente de lo que les quiero
hablar de las ideas de los procesos
creativos de cómo no interferir en las
ideas para que se conviertan
precisamente en realidades ideas
artísticas ideas que pueden ser de
cualquier tipo esta muchacha me preguntó
algo que nadie lo había hecho nunca que
sí existía en mi vida algún momento en
el que decidí ser escritor
debo hacer una pausa y añadir que la
verdad que nunca me he considerado ni
periodistas ni escritor guionista que es
lo que soy actualmente sino una especie
de activista hoy lo sé por la pasión que
siento hacia las ideas y hacia la
creatividad claro como no tiene 18 años
sale de bachillerato de kino yo yo me
gradué antes pero propone una edad de
equipo no sabes que de repente como
etiquetar eso como como tú dices yo
quiero dedicar mi vida a la creatividad
a las ideas es más fácil decir yo quiero
ser un abogado que tu familia te diga
esto o aquello o te lo recomiendo
pero estamos yo me pregunto eso y
recordé que justamente en este sitio
ocurrió eso
en este lugar de donde estábamos hace
una pila de años les estoy hablando de
la edad media cuando cuando habían
periódicos y papel y no compraba y leía
las cosas ahí se enteraba de eso
una de mis primeras asignaciones tenía
18 años como reportero fue cubrir una
fiesta que había acá en este sitio
y yo cargaba una libreta menos mal que
no existía en las tablets ni nada de eso
puesto que esta historia no existiría yo
quería una libreta y me puse escribir lo
que vi en esa fiesta desde el punto de
vista de mi feeling es decir no escribía
técnicamente con una perfección
sencillamente dejaba fluir las ideas que
me llegaban a decir los datos a través
de mi coincidencia y lo ponía pues
aquellas parejas está besando sé aquella
pareja está disfrutando aquellos que
están peleando la música más sentir de
esta manera y me di cuenta me encontré
sonriendo disfrutando eso disfrutando lo
que estaba escribiendo y una chica
parada y me puse a escribir un párrafo
sobre ella sobre su mirada sobre lo que
estaba haciendo sobre
su actitud hacia las demás personas
porque estaba como aislada
s en ese momento descubrí
y es la única manera en la que se
escribirá hasta el día de hoy que
mientras las ideas son más puras menos
edulcoradas y de alguna manera logramos
plasmar las bien sea como arte cocina
etcétera con educación con lo que sea
algo nos conecta con eso porque en
realidad todos estamos conectados
yo les invito a hacer un ejercicio
simplemente de voltear a los lados y ver
a la gente que tienen junto a ustedes
que de repente ni siquiera los has visto
en las horas que tenemos acá todos
estamos conectados y yo me di cuenta de
eso esa noche y ya pasaré porque quise
ser escritor desde esa noche
esta muchacha se me acerca de que estaba
por allá sola y me pregunta que estoy
escribiendo yo soy reportero y
si escribes una crónica sobre esto y me
pidió que le leyera algo perdón me pidió
leer algo pero mi letra era tan horrible
que sencillamente preferí leerse lo por
eso se mantiene hasta el día de hoy
y ella me dijo algo que lo escuchado
muchísimas veces a lo largo de los años
oye eso que tú escribiste es algo que yo
pensé
y sencillamente porque lo escribí sin
pensar demasiado
sencillamente dejándome llevar
entonces ustedes se preguntarán a
decidiste ser escritor en ese momento no
al día siguiente cuando me desperté y
ella estaba a mi lado
en ese momento dije voy a ser escritor
una de las cosas maravillosas de todo
esto voy a citar a david lynch que es
uno de mis cineastas favoritos no es muy
popular les recomiendo que vean algo
cualquier cosa o sea por el amor a dios
cristo cristal que sea vean algo de
david lynch quien dice atrapar en una
idea con otra comunidad tan poderosa que
tenemos todo lo que tú vas a sentir se
resume en eso electricidad y
conocimiento la idea puede ser de lo que
sea
puede ser algo como que te pase por la
cabeza que quieres hacer un cohete el
fucking cohete no va a llegar a ninguna
parte pero imagínate qué dedicas un fin
de semana a construir tu cohete de lata
de madera de lo que sea
y está con tus amigos y te pregunta qué
hiciste el fin de semana
un cohete
imagínate tú entonces el proceso
creativo
es algo que nos une porque esto nos ha
pasado muchísimo digan si es falso que
leen algo escucho en un discurso lee un
poema alguien dice algo y dentro de
ustedes surge el ya yo había pensado en
eso ya había pasado dentro de mí eso por
un motivo muy sencillo que actualmente
la gente especialista en la física
cuántica lo está tratando de explicar y
de masticar para que podamos entender
que todos estamos conectados realmente
un nivel de conciencia todos estamos
entre una especie de sistema de
conciencia de dónde llegan las ideas
las ideas son datos que nuestro cerebro
procesa y después sencillamente les
damos el uso o no que queremos a estas
ideas
esta imagen
por favor detenta imagen me encanta
y se ve tan cuchi realmente diga si es
mentira
esto es la representación del libro the
catcher in the rye de jd salinger
algunos lo conocerán otros no
su protagonista tiene 12 años y se llama
holden caulfield
holden 12 años tiene nada más una idea
de vida es decir él quiere en su futuro
hacer una sola cosa ese sí está claro
dentro de todos los parámetros que habló
aquel amigo este molde está más claro
que el carrizo holder solamente quieres
ser the catcher in the rye la traducción
de ese libro siempre estaba errada pues
lo llaman el guardián en el centeno
realmente es kutcher de receptor él
quiere ser el receptor en el centeno es
decir él imagina que hay un campo de
centeno y el centeno crece muy alto y
hay niños jugando cerca y no ven que hay
un precipicio
y el a los 12 años quiere pasar el resto
de su vida siendo el receptor estando
bajo para que los niños que se caigan
nos mueran
es una idea
desde el punto de vista mío bastante
noble para un chavito de 12 años
o no
no
the catcher in the rye es el libro de
cabecera de todos los asesinos en serie
más famosos infame de la historia de la
humanidad
lo que para mí o para algunos de ustedes
les parece tierno les parece humano le
parece bondadoso que un niño de 12 años
quiera dedicarse a salvar la vida de
otros niños afecta de una manera
realmente horrible mentes distorsionadas
aun cuando la idea original
es realmente bonita si se quiere
pero toca hay que admitir eso de que el
santo quiere estar recibiendo a otros
porque no se mueran pues pero los
asesinos en series más importantes
cortantes no no quiero utilizar esa
palabra más infames de la historia
sienten que jd salinger escribió ese
libro pensando en ellos
ellos se ven a sí mismos como holden
caulfield
increíble no de esa manera su cerebro
procesa el hecho de que en vez de salvar
a los niños ellos deben dejarlos caer
y esto lo dijo el asesino de john lennon
quién está obsesionado con el libro y
decía que su interpretación no era
salvar a los niños sino que
sencillamente se cayeran los niños
y para él john lennon era uno de los
niños
esta cita es muy importante y es clave
en la actualidad lo que mueve el mundo
no son las máquinas sino las ideas
pero para que ocurra eso debemos dejar
de ser unos robots es decir debemos
darle un stop a
al menos un momento en nuestras vidas
diariamente es decir
con esto creamos una serie de rutinas en
nuestra vida rutinaria ustedes se
levantan tienen su trabajo hacen café
hay poca aventura o pocas
sensaciones nuevas y diferentes en el
día a día para la gran mayoría de
nosotros el día a día transcurre de una
manera en que ya está planificada con la
llegada de estos aparatos incluimos otro
factor más pues entonces está la gente
que tiene la rutina de que a cierta hora
tiene que montar la historia en tal red
a cierta hora tiene que chequear tal
otra red o los mensajes por acá el
bombardeo que recibimos y que
gustosamente aceptamos y damos también
se convierte en parte de una rutina que
está haciendo que nos enfoquemos en
cosas que impiden que nuestro cerebro
pueda procesar ideas innovadoras ideas
nuevas
de billings decía que por ejemplo le
funciona mucho sentarse simplemente a
tomar un café y calmar la mente y
llegaban ideas y las recibía y por eso
salían sus películas pues también
funciona muchísimo manejar escuchar una
canción y con eso tengo un lado mi
cerebro ocupado y otro lado buscando
datos y recibiendo ideas
qué son las mismas ideas que pueden
tener todos ustedes y de repente si nos
olvidamos de esto un rato en algún
momento una hora al día podemos tener
ideas que se conviertan en
emprendimientos que cambien la vida de
muchos ideas de no sé un todólogo que
crea inventé algo para que gente como a
mí no le dé terror y la odontólogo o
cosas parecidas
pero tenemos que regresar a
lo que considero yo es el por qué
estamos acá
qué es experimentar
para mí es tan triste sentarme en un
café y ver a cuatro personas sentadas y
cada uno con su teléfono y ni siquiera
se ven las caras
piense en eso para eso ni siquiera se
encuentran pues para eso ni siquiera se
ve
porque si estamos ocupados o enfocados
totalmente
en algo como esto o en nuestras rutinas
nos absorbe de una manera tan grande
pasa eso que no nos damos cuenta de
cuándo llega la gran idea
la idea que puede ser cualquier tontería
para otros pero que para nosotros puede
ser algo que nos cambie
y hay algo muy interesante cualquier
idea que te pueda cambiar a ti lo puede
cambiar a él
yo escuché un cuento hace unos días no
sé si es verdad pero una señora estaba
diciendo que se le había dañado le
habían robado el teléfono del smartphone
y durante unos meses tuvo que tener eso
que llamaba un gallito
cuando la señora tuvo su gallito
recuerdo
que llevaba tres años sin hacer lo que
más le gustaba que era tejer
el teléfono le había distraído de tal
manera que ya no tejía o sea ya llevaba
tres años sin tener nada y lo he
olvidado
y me trató el gallito comenzó a tejer
nuevamente
y según ella le describía a esta persona
con la que estaba hablando si yo era el
metiche que estaba escuchando la cosa
que estaba tejiendo cosas hermosas que
incluso las estaba vendiendo y estaba
comenzando un emprendimiento con eso
porque se había desenfocado de esa
rutina del smartphone que la tenía
prácticamente atada
entonces qué es lo que queda
y no sé que se me hizo la última lámina
pero bueno aquí
qué es lo que nos queda
lo que nos queda sencillamente es
reconocernos saber que no estamos solos
saber que formamos parte de un colectivo
saber que podemos y debemos estar
integrados y que tendremos que
atrevernos y que no tenemos que tener
miedo de nada
fracaso
para castró eso no existe
porque el hecho de que a alguien no le
parezca algo que hiciste no es un
fracaso lo hiciste es tu idea y la
llevaste a la realidad
si me pasa la próxima estaríamos felices
pero web
x
que nos queda en todos los señores
no esperar iluminar un bombillo
ok
las ideas dicen que iluminan yo prefiero
recomendarles a todos ustedes que hagan
algo muchísimo más radical que eso que
es sencillamente
romper el cristal y ver más allá
explorar aventurarse romper y me hace
que eso es la rutina de su vida rompan
con eso aunque sea diez minutos aunque
sea media hora
viva interconecten se hablen todo que se
escuchen se discutan
construya su robot construya su cohete
construya lo que les dé la gana hagan
algo agarren tierra y toquen la y
sientan la desde cuando no hacen eso
desde cuando no hacemos eso
porque cada idea original que nos llegue
sin edulcorar caída que podamos
desarrollar va a generar un cambio en
nosotros y les aseguro que como pasó con
esta señora va a generar un cambio en la
otra persona y de esa manera descubrimos
que estamos unidos y de esa manera
descubrimos que somos una sociedad y de
esa manera descubrimos que no estamos
solos y que juntos podemos lograr
wherever lo que nos dé la gana gracias
[Música]